Now that our program draws the people in the social network, we need to make it
draw the friendships. I wrote a main method that creates three people, Sarah,
Cheng-Han, and Cay, and then adds Cay and Cheng-Han to my friends. When I run
this main method, It draws connections from me to Cheng-Han and me to Cay. This
dot means that Cheng-Han is in my friends list, but not necessarily that I'm in
his. Your task now is to fix the person class so that when you run this main
method, it draws this picture. With the lines. Each person gets a picture when
the object's constructed. And when someone adds a friend, you draw a line, from
the person who who has a new friend, to the person who is the new friend. The
lines for now should just connect all of the top left corners of the pictures.
This is a pretty complicated task right now. You might be thinking, you're not
really sure what to do first. So let's chat a little. Here's most of our code
for the Person class. You're only missing get friends at the bottom. And
y-coordinate over here. In which method should we add code that draws a line
between friends? The constructor, addFriend, unfriend, getFriends, or somewhere
else?